[Music]
your interstellar police squad has
tracked a group of dangerous rebels to a
cluster of seven small planets
now you must apprehend them quickly
before their reinforcements arrive of
course the rebels won't just stay put
they'll try to dodge you by moving from
planet to planet but you have one major
advantage every hour your
state-of-the-art Cruiser can warp
between any two planets while they're
beat up smuggling ship can only jump to
an adjacent planet in that same time
these rebels don't like to stay put
every time they can relocate they will
your scouts tell you that the
approaching rebel fleet is 10 hours away
you can't risk letting the rebels escape
can you devise a sequence for searching
the planets that's guaranteed to catch
them in 10 warps or less no matter what
moves they make rounding up the rebels
won't be easy for one you have no way of
knowing which planet they're on to begin
with and without that information it's
hard to determine where they'll move
next so where do you begin when tackling
problems of this kind it often helps to
simplify things so you can better
understand their dynamics let's imagine
that this cluster has the same
arrangement but no outermost planets
leaving only the four in the center we
still don't know which planet the rebels
start on but there's one key feature the
third planet is adjacent to all others
which means the rebels either start
there and move somewhere else or start
on one of the other planets and have no
choice but to move to Planet 3 simply
checking Planet number 3 twice in a row
would do the trick
adding the three outer planets adds a
bit more complexity but the same
strategy remains we want to check the
planets in an order that will eventually
corner the rebels and there's another
insight that can help us each our the
rebels move from an even-numbered planet
to an odd-numbered planet or vice versa
this gives us a way to simplify the
problem by dividing the planets into two
subsets and tackling each one separately
for starters let's assume the rebels
begin on an even-numbered planet either
2 4 or 6 so we'll search planet 2 first
if they're not there they must have
started on either 4 or 6 which means
they can move to 3 5 or 7 Planet 3 at
the center gives them the most options
for their next move so we'll want to
check their next if we don't find them
they must have been at Planet 5 or 7
meaning they'll next move to 4 or 6
let's now search Planet four if they're
not there they must have gone to the
sixth planet and can only flee to three
or seven if we next scour Planet three
and don't find them
we know they went to Planet seven and
are now cornered they can only move to
Planet six where we'll apprehend them on
our fifth search of course this plan
only works assuming that the rebels were
on an even-numbered planet in the first
hour but what if that assumption was
wrong in that case they must have
started on an odd-numbered planet and
because they moved to an adjacent planet
every hour their location must alternate
between odd and even numbered planets
this means that if they were on an
odd-numbered planet to start after five
moves they'd be on an even number
so if our first five searches missed
them because our assumption that they
started on an even-numbered planet was
wrong all we have to do now is repeat
the sequence searching the planets in
order two three four three six two three
four three six leaves the rebels nowhere
to run
thanks to your deductive reasoning order
is restored to the galaxy your friends
Harry Ron and Hermione are big film
buffs Hermione even knows how many times
Harry and Ron have seen Titanic she
sends the group a text letting Ron and
Harry know that they've each seen
Titanic and that one of them has seen it
one more time than the other Harry and
Ron respond with the following flurry of
texts
did you watch Titanic more than I did I
have no idea
me neither do you know now yes indeed
really then so do I so here's the
question for you what's the sum of the
possible number of times that Ron
watched Titanic in a moment will tell
you how to check your answer on one of
our favorite websites the reason we love
brilliant is that it teaches you
problem-solving tools and strategies
that you can apply to all sorts of
riddles berlin's puzzle library is
enormous interesting and carefully
curated to help you hone your
problem-solving skills visit brilliant
org slash Ted ed to check it out and use
that link so they know we sent you as an
added bonus the first eight hundred
thirty three of you to visit that link
will receive 20% off the annual premium
subscription fee also if you're still
wondering how many times the Wizards may
have watched Titanic we left a link in
the description that jumps you straight
to the solution